you know there are certain things that
are uh
guaranteed one of those things
is republican hypocrisy over the course
of the last several decades it has
become
crystal clear in the minds of anybody
who's paid attention that republicans
love to talk a big game when democrats
are in control
about budgets they whine and cry from
the rooftops
how are we going to pay for that
and it's not an altogether unreasonable
question
if asked in good faith but during the
the presidency of donald trump that an
extra seven or so trillion dollars
was added to the national debt
while we were in the midst of economic
boom times
a trillion to a trillion and a half
dollar deficits
every year even when things were great
when we should be
squirreling away money for a rainy day
preparing for a time when there would be
an economic downturn
we were we were letting the rich off
uh the fox into the hen house
the rich all kinds of tax cuts
adding to the national debt
well now the democrats are in charge
there are several proposals that they're
trying to make that they're
they're forwarding in hopes that
christian cinema and joe manchin
won't get in the way
this new york times article senate
democrats begin
3.5 trillion dollar push for big
bold social change a senate budget
blueprint
which democrats hope to pass this week
would ease
passage of legislation that would mark
the biggest expansion of the social
safety net
in nearly 60 years and this is good
news especially in the state that we
find ourselves
in covin
people on the brink of financial
collapse
millions and millions of americans
almost ready to be evicted from their
domiciles because they cannot pay
their rent people are in crisis
study after study after study over the
course of the last few years
have indicated that a large
percentage of americans could not
withstand
an unexpected 400 charge
expense things aren't great for
millions of americans and we need to
update how we take care
of those in need reading from this
article
democrats formally began their push on
monday for the most significant
expansion of the nation's social safety
net since the great society
of the 1960s unveiling a budget
blueprint
that would spend 3.5 trillion dollars on
health care
child and elder care education
and climate change the budget resolution
which the senate democrats
hope to pass by the end of this week
would allow the caucus to piece together
social policy legislation this fall paid
for by raising taxes on the wealthy
large inheritances and corporations
should all 50 senators who caucus with
democrats hold together
the measure could pass the senate
without a republican vote
nullifying the filibuster threat
democrats plan to take up the measure as
soon as the senate approves a separate 1
trillion
bipartisan infrastructure bill which by
the way
is a far cry from the multi-trillion
dollar infrastructure proposal
that biden wanted why
one because of the recalcitrant
um joe manchin the aforementioned joe
manchin
but also because republicans they're not
in the business of getting things done
they're in the business of opposition
uh the one trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill
which is scheduled for a vote at 11 am
tuesday
together the measures could secure
virtually all of president biden's 4
trillion
economic agenda rebuilding the nation's
roads bridges rail lines water systems
and electricity grid
while expanding public education social
welfare
and health care and remaking the federal
tax code
that is important democrats are hard at
work
bobbing and weaving and dodging the
arrows of republicans
who aren't in the business of progress
and democrats are trying to get
something done for the american people
to update
our country to refresh the way we do
things
because if this is the largest uh the
largest the biggest suspension of a
social security social safety net nearly
60 years
what are we doing if we're allowing
republicans to completely control the
narrative
like we have for for a generation
on the minimum wage what are we doing
if we we want to claim we live in
modernity we need to start acting like
it we need to start leading
like it we need to start legislating
like it
if the congress can make all kinds of
exceptions because of covid to update
their voting proxy rules we certainly
can do that
surrounding this and allowing
republicans to get in the way
especially where it relates to the
filibuster
isn't leadership if you ask me
it's cowardice one of our sponsors today
is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
and you'll get 10 percent off
all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link
is right underneath this video